Uh I'm from lit hub and uh what is Islam
and what lit hub can do for Islam? Uh
lead hub is focus on the smart boat and
mini PC. Thank you. The brothers asked
two question. Number one, what is Islam?
And number two, what can his company do
for Islam? Yes. Thank you Mr. As far as
the first question is concerned,
Islam comes from the root word salam
which means peace.
It's also derived from the Arabic word
silm which means to submit your will to
God. So Islam means peace acquired by
submitting your will to God. Can the
audio Can the technician increase the
volume
please? Can the audio technician
increase the volume of it? Allah and
even the monitor speaker. Yesah. So
Islam means peace acquired by submitting
a will to Almighty God. And anyone who
submits his will to Almighty God, he's
called as a
Muslim. Islam is a religion in which we
believe that there is only one
God, the Almighty, all powerful, the
creator, the sustainer. To him belongs
everything in this
world. And we have been bought in this
world to worship
him. Allah says in
15:56 that we have created the men and
the jin not but to worship him. So Islam
is a religion of peace by submitting a
will to God. And since God is our
creator, he knows best what is good and
what is bad for us. For
example, when you buy a machine, along
with the machine comes an instruction
manual. Right or wrong? Yes, you're
right. The more the complicated the
machine, the more is the requirement of
instruction manual. Correct. Correct. If
you allow me to call the human being a
machine, there is no more complicated
machine than the human being. Do you
agree? It's not a machine, but if you
allow me to call it a machine, it is the
most complicated machine on the face of
the earth. Correct. You're right. Do you
think it requires instruction manual?
The instruction manual of the human
being.
It is the glorious Quran. The glorious
Quran which is the last and final
revelation of Almighty God revealed to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon
him. This is the instruction manual for
the human being. The dos and don'ts how
you should use this machine. What is
good for the human being? What is bad
for the human? All this is mentioned. So
our creator who has made us has sent
this through many messengers. The last
and final messenger is prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him. So we as human beings
should know our creator and should know
what is good, what is bad for
us. And anyone who follows the guidance
of almighty god and follows his
instruction and submits his will and
agrees there is one god and agreed
prophet Muhammad is a messenger of god
he's called as a muslim
brother you said you don't belong to any
religion so do you believe there is god
and from now on I believe you believe
there's god I believe I believe god okay
do you have some definition of God.
Uh I think the the first one is about
the population for human uh Islam and
you know the the population they raised
a lot and also so for this one that's
many people they contracted the right
direction to the god. So I also agree
with you. Thank you. So which definition
of god do you believe? Because god is
one but different people have different
definitions.
Different people some people make idol
of God. Do you agree God can have an
idol? No, I only I'm only one. So we as
Muslims do not believe that God can have
an idol because God has got no images.
We believe that God is
one. And the best definition in the
Quran is surah chapter number 112 verse
number 1 to4 which
says Allah one and only Allah Allah the
absolute
eternal he begets not nor is he
begotten there's nothing like him so
this is a fourand definition of almighty
god who we call as Allah that he's one
he's absolute eternal he begets not know
he's begotten that means he doesn't have
father, doesn't have mother, doesn't
have
children. And there's nothing like him.
He's unique. So do you believe in these
four qualities of God?
Yeah, I agree with you. You believe?
Mashallah. And brother, do you believe
that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
is the messenger of God? Yes. Mashallah.
So for any human
being to accept Islam, there are two
criteria required.
two criteria. Number one, believe that
there is God. If anyone believes there's
one God, he doesn't have image. He's not
like a human being. He's all powerful.
And secondly, if he believes that
Prophet Muhammad is a messenger, he
becomes a
Muslim. Later on the practices come,
praying five times, fasting, all that is
later on. But the minimum two criteria
required for any human being to enter
the fold of Islam, the religion of peace
is believe there is one God and no one
is worthy of worship except him and
believe that prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God. So do you believe in
these two things?
I agree. I believe. So do you want to
accept Islam?
Yes.
Okay. You know the
brothers they are very happy because we
have about 2 billion people in the world
and here there are about maybe 15 20,000
Muslims. So when you say you became a
Muslim they want to welcome you to the
fold of Islam. I will say the same thing
what I said in Arab in English I'll say
in Arabic you can repeat after me. Same
thing what I explained in English. I say
in Arabic you can repeat it. Ashu.
You can repeat what I'm saying in
Arabic.
Ashu Ashu. Ashu. Allah. Allah.
Illahill.
Ashu.
Muhammad. Muhammad. Abdul Abdu.
My you become a Muslim.
I will just repeat the translation. I
will repeat the translation. Repeat in
English. I bear
witness. I bear witness I bear witness
that that there is no God there is no
God but Allah but Allah and I bear
witness and I bear witness that Prophet
Muhammad that Prophet Muhammad is is the
messenger the messenger and servant and
the server of Allah of Allah mashallah
mashallah
[Music]
[Applause]
I congratulate you for entering the fold
of
Islam. I would request the organizers if
you can give him a copy.
Okay.
[Applause]
Takb all brothers and sisters happy. We
welcome you to the fold of Islam. And
according to beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam anyone who
accept Islam all your previous sins are
washed away. All the good deeds that you
did are there but whatever wrong you did
is completely forgiven and I pray to
Allah subhanana wa tala give you the
best life in this world and the
thank you regarding your second part of
the question. Okay. What can you do for
me? You have already done. I wanted you
to accept Islam and you have done it.
You have already accepted Islam. That's
what would have made me the most
happiest person. So I would like to
thank you for fulfilling my desire.
Thank you very much, brother.
Yeah.
Do you have any other question? Yeah. Uh
for this is the first and the second.
The third Yeah. the the third one uh I
will will do what I believe and also you
teach to me. Thank you very much for
this point and uh at the same time I
also because lead hub also do many
charities for schools for education
system because the education is the is
the future for even from uh different
countries uh mostly and uh also China
and also the hub. So uh how can I do
better uh for little hop in Kenya? As
far as charity is concerned brother in
Islam minimum you have to give
2.5% of your annual saving whatever
excess wealth you have got according to
Islam 2.5% of that wealth maybe you have
some gold or some extra not your basic
requirement clothes is basic requirement
one car is basic whatever excess wealth
you have in Islam you have to give 2.5%
of that excess wealth in charity every
lunar year. So maybe if you have
$100,000 extra a saving, not counting
your house, not counting your clothes,
not counting a requirement, whatever
extra wealth you have, maybe have kept
in the bank, have cash in the hand or in
the form of jewelry or in the form of
investment, whatever excess wealth you
have including the stock of your
company, 2.5% of that you should give in
charity. You can give to the poor
people, you can give it to the needy
people. And there are eight categories.
So since you are involved in the field
of education there you can always
contact the organizers the journey of
faith. Thank you so much. Faith you can
contact them and surely you can see how
you can help them. That's the brother
Abu Sufyan is there. If you can share
your number with him inshallah he'll be
in touch with you and whatever extra
knowledge you require of Islam you can
very well contact the organization. If
not, you can even take my number. You
can call me. I'm staying Malaysia.
You're most welcome, brother. Thank you
very much. Thank you, Dr. Zucker. Neil,
nice to meet you here.
[Applause]